hello everyone and happy Friday my name
is Zachary Lupine and I'm an avionics
reliability engineer here at SpaceX I'll
be your host for today's starlink
Mission which marks spacex's 11th launch
of the year and 200.
for those of you following the starlink
program starlink is now available in 47
countries and 59 markets around the
world and today we are sending another
51 starlink satellites to orbit
currently weather and range are both
green for launch and we are proceeding
with a t0 time of 11 12 a.m Pacific time
from Vandenberg space Force Base at pad
4 East
the teams are currently tracking no
issues with the vehicle or spacecraft
should see those strong back arms
opening up here shortly
and there you can see them going
up next at T minus three minutes we
should hear that stage one has completed
liquid oxygen loading
sitting adjacent to the Falcon 9 rocket
is the transporter erector or te which
is the truss structure next to the
rocket that is used for rollout and to
route propellants and electrical power
to the vehicle in preparation for launch
foreign
the weather at Vandenberg space Forest
station is currently looking pretty darn
clear today
stage one lock flow complete
at T minus three minutes the Falcon 9
first stage is fully loaded with rp1 and
locks and we're awaiting completion of
locks load on the second stage in about
52 seconds from now
as a reminder the Falcon 9 rocket uses a
fuel rp1 and an oxidizer liquid oxygen
and you can just make out some of the
white clouds forming on the body of the
rocket this is because the booster is
very cold as we slowly vent a little bit
of liquid oxygen
stage two last flow complete
and there's that call out of stage two
locks load completion Falcon 9 is now
fully loaded with 1 million pounds of
fuel and liquid oxygen
the booster you see on your screen is
flying for the ninth time today having
previously supported the Sentinel 6
Michael Frey like Mission the NASA Dart
Mission and six Starling missions
after liftoff and Stage separation the
booster is scheduled to land on our
drone ship of course I still love you
reusability allows SpaceX to refly the
most expensive parts of the rocket which
in turn drives down the cost of space
access coming up next we should hear
that Falcon 9 is in startup which means
the rocket is on internal power
and there's that call out that Falcon 9
is now in startup and the rocket is on
internal power
LDS go for lunch
and as you just heard the launch
director has given the final go to
proceed for launch let's sit back and
watch as Falcon 9 takes our 51 starlink
satellites into space T-minus 30 seconds
15 seconds
10 9 8 7.
six five or three two one engines full
power and lifts off of starlink group
2-5 gopal ghost darling
and what the chamber pressures novel
at t plus 35 seconds Falcon 9 has
successfully lifted off from
vandenberg's space launch complex four
East at 11 12 a.m Pacific time
our in Telemetry nominal
vehicle is supersonic
there's that call out that Falcon 9 is
supersonic this means the vehicle is
currently going faster than the speed of
sound Max Q
and there's that call out for Max Q this
means that the vehicle is currently
experiencing the greatest amount of
external stresses as it ascends through
the Earth's atmosphere
back chill
and we are about one minute away from a
series of events Mikko stageep scs-1 and
fairing separation Mikko or main engine
cutoff is where all nine of the Merlin
1D engines on the first stage shut down
stage separation is when the first and
second stages separate scs-1 or second
engine start 1 is where we light the
Merlin vacuum on the second stage and
fairing separation is when the two
fairing halves separate and fall away
from the second stage
keep an eye out for these events which
will happen in Rapid succession
State separation confirmed
and recognition
bearing separation confirmed
and there we heard those call outs for
main engine cutoff stage separation
scs-1 and fairing separation we will be
attempting to recover both fairing
halves today using our recovery vessel
NRC Quest both of the fairing halves
flying on today's Mission are flight
proven with one half flying for the
fifth time and the other it's sixth
and just as a reminder on the left side
of the screen is the Falcon 9 first
stage and on the right side you can see
the second stage which is carrying the
starlink satellites
currently the first stage is on its way
back to Earth towards our drone ship of
course I still love you which is
stationed in the Pacific Ocean
the mvac engine attached to the second
stage which you see on the right side of
your screen stages are following nominal
trajectories
that second stage is continuing its burn
which will last for another several
minutes
as I mentioned earlier today starlink
Mission marks spacex's 210th Mission
overall and 11th Mission just this year
and with the first stage on the left
side of your screen you can see a pair
of those titanium grid fins measuring
about four feet by five feet those are
the primary mechanism used to control
the booster during its descent
and it looks like that booster has
reached apogee and is now actually
descending back towards Earth
as a reminder starlink is a satellite
internet constellation designed and
manufactured by SpaceX to provide high
speed low latency internet to people
living in remote and Rural locations
around the globe
and just as a reminder on the left side
of your screen is the Falcon 9 first
stage which is coming back to Earth to
perform its landing and the second stage
with the Merlin vacuum engine visible is
on the right
both vehicles are still following
nominal trajectories
stage one that's your grand startup
there's that call out for the stage one
entry burn stage one which we also call
the booster has ignited engines one five
and nine to slow it down for atmospheric
re-entry
the first stage used to launch our 51
starlink satellites into space today is
flying for its ninth time
having each one FTS has saved having
previously supported the Sentinel 6
Michael fry lake Mission the NASA Dart
Mission and six starlink missions
and you heard that call out that the
entry burn on the first stage has also
completed
stage two FTS has saved
page one is trans Sonic
and there you heard that the first stage
is now transonic which means it is
traveling near the speed of sound
terminal guidance
stage one Landing burn
and there's confirmation that the stage
one Landing burn has started in
preparation for touchdown on our drone
ship of course I still love you
stage one Landing light deploy
stage
and there you've heard and saw that
Falcon 9 has successfully landed on our
drone ship of course I still love you in
the Pacific Ocean this marks our 172nd
overall Landing of an orbital class
rocket including Falcon 9 and Falcon
heavy missions
nominal orbit insertion
and if you heard that call out we had
nominal orbital insertion of our
starlink satellites
and with confirmation
and with confirmation of successful
first stage landing and second engine
cutoff that wraps up our coverage for
now be sure to check our social media
for confirmation of Starling satellite
deployment thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time